[Music]
chicken tenders
what about them are under threat of the
supply chain crisis and are now probably
going to be [ __ ] expensive at the
stores our chickens going extinct are
chickens going extinct
what's happening we should we should ask
alexa that one where all the tenders
going
they're just done the chicken and the
chickens are going away the chickens are
running away only the tenders
apparently apparently the eyes are fine
breasts are fine breasts are fine yeah i
know right
the wings are not a shortage
the the wild there was though uh i
believe there was a wing shortage that's
why wingstop started to uh
do chicken thighs buy stuff yeah thai
stuff yeah they started doing this you
ever had thigh stop no it's good is that
good it's good it tastes exactly like
wing stop but instead of eating a wing
you're eating a thigh so it's just a
[ __ ] ton of flavor on a chunk of meat so
you instead of like taking like eight
wings you'll get like four thighs but
they're like big enough
do they still do that they do this it's
called thigh stop though they changed i
think you guys would like it actually
you gotta go you gotta go to a wing stop
where you you have to go to the back up
a thigh stop like look at that change
the logo they have both wing stops and
thigh stock what the hell and it's just
thighs yeah because i think thighs are
better you get way more meat and then
nice and juicy and this episode is
brought to you by thigh socks i know man
but the skin to me ratio is off dude
but if there's one thing you're gonna
complain about with chicken thighs it is
the skin to meat ratio
wings there is more there's more flavor
but the thighs have more meat i enjoy i
enjoy the wing experience though there's
something about like ripping [ __ ]
what's your favorite wing place
well right now i'm in glendale so i'm
going to hot wings cafe hella pretty
solid it's like i gotta go all flats man
you can't get no drumettes that shit's
like a lying uh drumstick you know why
because the drummer is actually white me
that's why it's a little drier yeah it's
tougher and drier man
i thought it was a baby drumstick and
then i realized the anatomy of the
chicken was like that's a part of the
wing folk oh
[ __ ] yeah those are bomb though still
yeah
why is there such a supply issue
everywhere [ __ ] tenders all kinds of
[ __ ] do you think it's a conspiracy
well a year ago there was a uh
beef and pork or something because of
the processing plants and that was
slowed down because the workers weren't
coming in and on top of that like i i
remember they had to just slaughter a
ton of [ __ ] pigs and just get rid of
them one time because uh there was there
was like a bottleneck in the system oh
that's right i remember that cause i saw
um videos where they were just pouring
milk down the drain as well since they
didn't have a way to transport the milk
i guess from the farm to the
supermarkets or the processing plants or
whatever wow so they're just getting rid
of it because it was expiring yeah it
was like well what do we do with it like
you can't even give it away to we can't
get it to people so it was like oh they
don't got the trucks yeah there was not
enough truck drivers back then i guess
they were crying over spilled milk yes
[Music]
i met your match tasty kids staple joins
items like maple syrup wine and spirits
take out containers and coffee cups
among the many products that have been
made more scarce or more expensive by
pandemic related supply chain issues
pandemic [ __ ] us up
uh shelves have been empty recently
restaurants have been out of chicken
tenders and it makes it very difficult
when there are kids to feed it's a very
good exactly
what are the kids what's gonna happen to
raising canes that's their entire
they're gonna switch to dino nuggets
but that's like the same thing though
so [ __ ] that's literally we gotta fly
raising cane stock when it dips so it
says chicken tenders which are the
which are the smaller fillet of a whole
chicken breast require more processing
to package and sell than chicken nuggets
which are made of scrap meat from the
whole bird that is why chicken tenders
are harder to find or more costly
according to industry experts oh it's
different from chicken breast you only
get a certain amount of tenders per
chicken so it's like if you get a breast
there's i think it comes with like one
or two uh tenders from the breast what
is it
of the chicken brother it's a slender i
think it's part of like a i think it
actually part is there's like tendon
inside of it so so the breast here it
has two of us i think so and it's along
the side the tender's along the side and
it's very inside
pretty much because it's lean still it's
very good it's very cheap like trader
joe's i i get chicken tenders a lot not
anymore i know [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] but it's
like seven bucks for like a pound and a
half of just chicken and it's pure it's
juicy it's juicy
it's a little bit of fat than just the
dried chicken breast for sure it's
easier to cook you can't go wrong you
gotta think of it like how many chickens
are in that one pound i don't know i
think about that all the time i think
about that with disneyland turkey legs
like where the [ __ ] are all the turkeys
walking around with no legs because
they're all they ground the turkey meat
oh that's where i thought there was just
like legless turkeys everywhere like
surf and soup you just put them out
you just drop them back in that's what
they do with some uh crabs yeah you can
harvest them and rip off the claw and
throw the crab back into the water do
they regrow the crab i think so no they
throw it back into the ocean it's almost
humane crab should be not as expensive
then what is this it's like the king
crab legs yeah something like that oh
yeah it's got to be a bunch of crab
bodies that are just walking not walking
well it grows back after a while so
those are the big legs have you guys
been to the bakken all lately
because you know most buffets they got
the cold crab lace yeah got this freshly
steamed hot one for real i gotta go i
haven't been there in ages vegas [ __ ]
out of here bro we can't enjoy that he
always brings that back price of a value
pack of chicken tenders has gone up
nearly a dollar per pound since the same
time last year from three dollars and
two cents to 3.99 on average what are we
gonna do major chains like kentucky
fried chicken and amw have changed their
marketing plans to omit tenders from
promotions in order to avoid selling out
of them oh my
god what is the world gonna do see this
is the beginning of the apocalypse dude
now all i want is chicken tenders now
that's all i want to eat it it starts
with the chicken tenders and then it's
gonna go with no food
wow no tenders no food it's interesting
every time you go to like a nice
restaurant the kids menu is always
chicken tenders and mac and cheese yeah
or grilled cheese i kind of always love
the grilled cheeses they're extra butter
we're gonna have all these starving
children now yeah they gotta they gotta
eat the adult [ __ ] now they gotta eat
[ __ ] stir-fried mushrooms have you
guys been to
asian cans i've never been not i've been
before
is it good i've only had like i've made
it my uh what's the word called like
routine
on my way back
i always get raising canes out and i
don't know why it's a tradition do you
like it no it sucks
it's not the best thing ever but what do
you get though like what do you get from
there like sandwich they don't have much
the chicken tenders i think it's just
one of those where like you pull into
bars though oh my god i have it and now
i have you gotta get the del taco at
barstow baby
all of that and i'm like what's what's
some new [ __ ] and i'm like oh raisin
canes wasn't that good last week and i'm
like let me try it again quality control
this time it's better you're a fan of
quality control that's what it is and
then i just get it again and after i get
it again it's i'm like i don't know but
that del taco at barstow that's the
that's the og one that's like the number
one first one right they got i don't
know but they still got the og menu what
do you get there
well their tacos are different they got
like a special barstool del taco maybe
i'll get that yeah that's different and
then they got those like tostada tacos
and they got those like bootleg wannabe
pretend mexican things and i think
that's the beauty of fast food
mexican food yeah i don't like it when
they try to be real mexican i like it
when they're like this is like this is
like panda express it's like fake [ __ ]
and you know what you're gonna get yeah
i have a feeling i'm gonna roll up to
del taco and just get raising cane still
what do you read it in the car
yeah i just sit there like a loser
i eat in like 10 minutes i get back on
the road do you eat the bread and the
fries too yeah make a little sandwich no
i don't i keep it apart is that he keeps
everything separate
he eats his fries first then his chicken
and then the bread are there are the
fries good though because i heard that
they were pretty good honestly
everything kind of sucks
but he still gets it every time i don't
know why i get it i don't know if it's
just like
bar still kind of just sucks in general
it's just me so it just matches well if
you're buying a [ __ ] louis vuitton
jacket for two dollars yeah
i don't know the crazy ass sales that
they have i like going to levi's
you know
outlets it's pretty tight clothes is
dope because you get crazy deals but i
don't know
when you guys get um like take out right
or like when you guys do drive through
and um you have a fresh [ __ ] bag of
fries do you start eating the fries
immediately or do you wait until you get
home and you have your [ __ ] like
whole ceremony and you pull it all out
and then you eat the fries what do you
do my meal doesn't even make it home
just so i know what it tastes like and
then when i get home i even got to pick
the right tv show and everything but
then by that time the fries are all
[ __ ] because i understand the burger
but the fries i feel like every second
that you wait it gets worse but i gotta
eat it together like
that i do both i think that's what i do
i eat like a couple fries and then i go
home i set it up if you have an air
fryer it's game changing
so you just throw it back in the air
fryer and then everything's like it's
brand new really yeah yeah fries so i
get two fries one for the car one do you
have an air fryer no bro joe get an air
fryer i gotta get an air fryer the next
day too
fried chicken fried chicken anything
fried anything you could dino nuggets
brussels sprouts brussels sprouts
broccolini
jalapeno poppers from jack in the box
all the paper poppers in general yes
you could make anything an air fryer see
i was thinking about buying one but i
was like now i don't need to get more
fat now there's so many that are like
cheap it's actually it's actually
healthier for you because of the
healthiest things you can cook because
you could get the fried texture without
having to dip it in oil really
i'll make breaded chicken tenders and
i'll throw in the airfryer and it'll
cook and it tastes just like it was
fried damn you can get chicken tenders
still though i heard those are rare i
know you used to get breaded chicken i
know not even chicken tenders now you
just get spreaded chicken
hit me up after the video's over i got
you all right the chicken tender black
dealer
[Music]
[Music]
you